hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lam waifu and today we
are considering trust and the idea of
true strength without a sign of
basically
any of the characters we're used to
talking about actually let's get into it
after all the time we spent with kilauea
last week episode 102 was all about gone
and trust and i'd like to think about
how trust and vulnerability is shared
and what it might mean going forward all
in the context of our little dude bro
steve mellon and his cute little tuft of
hair
little melon man followed gone for a
while before making himself known but
something i failed to consider
immediately was the idea that
he deliberately made himself known
before gone was out of the forest and
into a desert he chased him
to a new location yes it's impossible to
hold your breath forever but it shows
that as soon as steve had seen how gone
handled himself in the way in which he
did handle himself
he made his decision for all his
frustration with gone giving his trust
freely
steve didn't have a leg to stand on he'd
done exactly the same thing
and quite frankly that's kind of cute
and there's this deep-seated
understanding that's beginning to emerge
from this arc in which those who
remember what and who they were
those who are primarily human especially
they remember that humanity
they remember that piece of them that
felt something for someone else
or that piece of them that experienced
something else beyond the need to
predate or hide they were just people
and that normality about them is what
makes them magical in this setting
i'm a huge lover of the hero's call to
adventure and i'm even more a fan of it
when it's
a call that they would not have chosen
when it's a call
when it's not a call they wanted but a
call they got seeing what people do when
they're placed into situations they
didn't plan for like getting eaten by a
giant queen ant and existing with
chameleon powers then seeing your foster
father's head get sliced off by both the
person who ruled your island with an
iron fist in both the past life and this
one
see that that is fascinating to me
because it's the true show of behavior
and a true mark of who we are
more than gone and kiwa's situation
actually because gon and kilwa were
never normal the first
image we got of gone was him heaving a
giant
fish out of the water the first image we
got of kilwa was a perfectly ordinary
teenager as part of a gruelling exam
that kills many adults who attempt it
they walked into the decision with full
awareness of where it could lead
even if it hasn't led to where they
expected it to they knew that there
would be danger
and they walked toward it steve on the
other hand chameleon
simply lived a life and was punished for
it
and then punished again any choice he
makes now is a direct consequence of the
situation that he was thrust into so i
feel more intensely for him
and i like that so when he tells gon to
take his time to trust when he says i'm
sure it'll take
time for you to trust me because to you
i look like a monster
that's his humanity and it's very
telling of what he sees
as a monster he's observed others and
seen what they are
and who they are and what they'll do he
sees those who have given in to that
side of them and he sees
gone who has come from a similar
situation raised by his aunt as a
kindred spirit he also sees gone for
what he is which
is one of the first times it's been
stated to my recollection
at least too gone it's been said behind
his back but i don't know if it's often
said to the boy himself i think i
mentioned a while back that gone and
hisoka have a monstrous
similarity and that i could see gone
becoming sulky when he grows up what
steve is seeing in gone
is what i saw then someone who will
consciously step into danger to make a
point
and stay there because it's fun
somewhere between birth and
now gone learned that to get what he
wants he's going to have to feed that
urge to be a monster and what we've been
seeing this whole time
is a shift towards that monstrousness
it's why i've been so
interested in when we get to see him
kill which to date is only that one
crushed bug a number of episodes ago as
far as i'm aware
if we could do a benjamin button style
crossover it's the birth and development
of a monster from episode one to now
while
melian
is going the other way from monster back
to humanity
they meet in the middle and size each
other up and see that actually they're
perfectly matched gone's ability to
track is fascinatingly perfect as a
crossover for chameleon's special trick
and it is a truth universally
acknowledged that gone can't keep
himself hidden
unless he's hunting sookie meanwhile
king waistcoat is learning how to play
every game to learn the meta of every
stratagem in existence
since the vast majority of board games
we commonly play are actually war games
or at least the vast majority of early
board games that we commonly play
are actually war games this makes
perfect sense i do wonder as well how
much of this is the man who existed
before and how much is the man who
exists
now and it's a perfect counterpoint to
steve if you think about it really
because steve got to have a somewhat
good upbringing with a foster parent
good enough in any case that
he is willing to risk death to take
revenge on the bug who killed him
we know that king dudington had an awful
upbringing
and has a pretty ruthless history so his
interesting games could come
from who he was or it could come from
who he is
either way he seems to find games to be
genuinely engaging so i wonder how that
detail will be used if it's used at all
what we know is that he's honing his
strategic mind which can only make him
more dangerous
it would be easy to assume that the
antagonist in this case is resting but
no
the mental activation here is intense
and we're seeing him study to learn
about essentially his opponents since
they're largely human
and we finally meet the one who may be
able to match him
the one in the end credits we don't know
who she is but we want to find out right
okay
all nod yes and let's move on to episode
103
in episode 103 we continue the strategy
idea that was initiated in the last
episode and the major thing we're
learning right now is that it doesn't
matter how strong you
are a snot knows brat can always come in
and make you feel like an idiot huzzah
first not knows brats
we're also learning in great detail what
meroem's weakness is
in human form wanted to be the strongest
the best the smartest and wanted to do
so to make his father proud and reborn
he still seems to be
the same trying to beat everyone to
prove he is the smartest we already know
he's one of the strongest and definitely
the most ruthless heartless and a number
of other lessers except he wants to be
the nautilus so it's a strange way to
show that when you think about it
as far as we're aware there is only one
way to distract the king and that is to
put an
unconquerable task in front of him i
mean it's a good way to distract anyone
really but him specifically right now
that unconquerable task
is currently a game with a little girl
if she can keep him busy for long enough
the others might have to go out and
fight to protect him because it's all
consuming this need to be the best isn't
it it's nice when you see something
begin to take shape and it's even
nicer when it's something unexpectedly
simple for pito to say that if lionel
kitty can't deal with the situation that
the king
might have to and for there to be
genuine concern from violin butterfree
dude about the fact that the king hasn't
won yet
of all of them i think he's struck on
the real center of the problem
which is that there's a mental war being
waged right there on the board and the
king is
fighting on that front right now alone
yes he has the upper hand of being the
king and therefore fully capable of just
killing her immediately
she is after all an uncommonly stupid
girl but the greater problem is that
essentially the king is paralyzed until
the game is over
and the others are expected to deal with
the war on the more physical level
and speaking of unconquerable tasks
chitu has put himself into an equally
unconquerable task he thought he'd
caught morpheus but no
if anything he's actually trapped
himself welcome to the matrix
a hyperactive cat now has to not touch
his prey and that's hilarious and
awkward for him
a test of strength he probably would
have won a test of wills
yeah cheeto has cheeto cheetos
cheeto has lovely short shorts but i
really don't think they're going to be
enough
unconquerable positions like this and
outsmarting the predator that's
a lovely theme to have as an episode and
such
a switch from the last one given god's
inability to outsmart most people his
strength is in being deathly honest
about his situation
which enemies then underestimate sort of
the same as this little girl who only
opens her eyes to play games
and it's fascinating to see her eyes
only open for this because i'm fairly
sure
everyone sees images in their minds when
they think regardless of whether or not
they actually have vision
and so if she were to close her eyes i
wonder whether she would be genuinely
handicapped in a situation that she
wields the most power
and the more she wins the more we can
see the composure meroem
holds dropping as he gets more and more
angry with how easily she commands the
board his pride is going to be his
downfall as it
is for so many villains and he's a
pretty stereotypical villain in a lot of
ways which is why i focused on other
aspects of him because
you know he's a bad guy like what else
are you supposed to say about that
speaking of the bad guy there's
something very chilling in the idea that
the previous person to play the game
hanged himself
and the king's response is like oh yeah
just just bring him back i'm not done
i've been wondering about how enduring
or how powerful pito's ability actually
is in terms of the memories and
cognitive abilities of the people they
control but it seems that if the king
can demand they be brought back it means
they have all their mental capacities
was kite's aura activated i believe so
which means he has to be in there right
the puppet master can only use what's
available and thus we come to the nature
of a soul
and i really don't know whether that
conversation is going to help us so i'm
not going to have it today
we don't know at present what's
happening tequila but i imagine we're
going to jump cut to him being somewhat
alive and protected by his octobuddy the
plan as it started has been shifted on
so many levels at this point that it's
fun to see how
and why and when each character
compromises the rest of the group
gone not telling the others about his
new friend is an interesting one i
suppose he doesn't really need to worry
about catching or killing stevie wonder
speaking of stevie
how very dare he make the best call in
the series so far about knuckle
there are distinct distinct johnny bravo
connections firing on all cylinders now
that it's been said and the major
difference is that knuckle is happy to
cry
and and as much as he's a macho man he's
an emotionally in touch macho man and we
love our machismo with a healthy dose of
vulnerability and genuine care don't we
yeah we do
even stevie felt that vulnerability that
was offered despite saying that it
wouldn't change his view
thank you johnny before morel was taken
into naplan he set up some dudes to
protect the city
those dudes have thoroughly confused
lionel and
will continue to until he gets up close
how long does that work
how much scrutiny do they hold up to how
powerful are they how long will it take
for chitu to try to tempt morel before
morel tags him
where the hell is kilwa who is this
doctor
i have so many questions and these two
episodes were frankly fantastic
not the best i still don't know which is
my favorite i'm gonna wait till the end
of the series to figure that out but the
ideas involved are ones that i love to
consider
philosophically on my own nerdy time so
i'm glad to guess she brought them up
i'm gonna try watch some more now but
that means diving into new episodes so
for now
that's it from me if you enjoyed these
random philosophical random
randoms oh if you enjoyed these random
philosophical rambles hit the like
follow and subscribe button check out
the links here here and here
keep cool calm collected and strategic
and i'll see you next time